so I will be speaking at Baylor
University on April 9th I'll also be at
Boston University on April 4th that's
this Thursday but the speech at Baylor
has a supposedly Christian school by the
way he is attracting some negative
attention there's a currently a petition
underway to get the speech shut down so
far over a thousand people have signed
it last I last I saw calling for the
cancellation of my event there and I'm
hearing from some students on campus
that the outcry is it's pretty severe on
campus so I could be walking into a bit
of a chaotic situation here but we'll
we'll see let me just be honest with you
about about this I really take no
pleasure in this kind of thing I I know
that the impression that people have is
that conservatives come to give these
talks on campuses hoping for these kinds
of reactions hoping for the big outcry
and then the conservative enjoys the
outcry and loves the publicity and the
attention and really that's what this is
all about right it's just about it's
about but that's it's about the
publicity and attention and that may
well be the case in fact I'm convinced
it certainly is the case with some
conservatives and I'll admit that there
was a time when I did get a kick out of
this kind of thing where oh they started
up petition against me awesome right
well I really don't feel that way
anymore and I have him for a long time I
would actually like to just have a
rational and thoughtful dialogue
I'm not going to bail her for that for
this that that I would be much happier
if there was no petition and none of
that and it was just a normal calm
rational dialogue because that is
actually what I'm interested in I have
no interest in the theatrics I have no
interest in
new interest in a Q&A session that
really becomes an excuse for one person
after another to get up there and call
me a bigot and go for the applause line
and then we go back and forth and
somebody puts it on YouTube and blah
blah blah
that's probably what I'm walking into
but it's not what I want I'm not gonna
be scared away by it
but it just becomes a hollow spectacle
after a while and it's just sort of
useless and it's a waste of time you
know if I if I go down there and no one
is really interested in listening and it
just becomes a spectacle then it's a
waste of my time I would rather not go
it's a waste of everybody's time you
know anyone that comes to the speech
hoping for a rational dialogue it's a
waste of their time - so here's what I'm
going to try to try and do with with the
speech originally my plan was to talk
about the left's efforts to redefine
life marriage and gender which is why I
think in the petition it says that I'm
giving an anti LGBTQ presentation and I
guess that's what that's why they're
calling it that is because I was going
to talk about the left's efforts three
to find life marriage and gender and
then to discuss the effect that that
effort has had on society I wrote a book
on the topic down Holy Trinity so it's
just basically that but I suspect that
many of the people in attendance will be
of a leftist persuasion and therefore a
speech that sort of presupposes the
premise that it's bad to redefine life
marriage and gender won't be as useful
so maybe I won't do that that doesn't
mean I'm going to avoid these topics no
no don't don't think that for a second
instead I think it may be more
worthwhile if I were to talk about and
explain on a more fundamental level why
these things should not be defined
redefined so that if you come to the
speech even if you disagree with me
you'll have an opportunity to at least
learn
why a person might oppose abortion and
might believe that biological sex is not
subjective and is an immutable
unchangeable characteristic of a person
and so on you can at least find out what
it is exactly that you oppose if you're
going to continue opposing it you might
as well know what the argument is that
you're that you're against and I think
that you'll discover if you listen with
an open mind that what is at the root of
this belief system if we want to call it
social conservatism whatever what's at
the root of it is not actually bigotry
that's not what it's about it doesn't
mean that you'll agree at the end you
don't have to agree but you should at
least listen so that you know what
you're disagreeing with and so that's
that's what I plan to do I'm gonna
tackle these three topics life marriage
gender and and just talk about them on a
really basic level which as I said
considering that this is supposed to be
a Christian school you know in an ideal
world it shouldn't be necessary to
explain these kinds of things at a
Christian school but I think that it
apparently is so that's what I'm going
to do all right I signed on to Twitter
over the weekend to find that the
hashtag my white privilege was trending
and I discovered as you would have
discovered too if you got on Twitter
over the weekend that the the hashtag my
white my white privilege it was not a
bunch of people making fun of the idea
of white privilege
instead at least initially it was a
whole gaggle of guilt ridden white folks
solemnly confessing to all of the many
ways that they had been benefited from
this mysterious racial privilege so they
would talk about a way that they
benefited from white privilege and then
you know hashtag my white privilege
so let me I'm gonna read a couple of
these tweets to you
few of them just to give you an idea of
what these guilt-ridden white folks were
we're tweeting so one of the tweets says
I got caught stealing multiple times as
a teenager and they never called the
cops they just let me go with a warning
every period single period time period
hashtag my white privilige another one
says as a white woman when I get back
from the beach my newly darker tan skin
will be praised as making me prettier it
will be used as an opening to ask me
about my vacation no one will criticize
me
hashtag my white privilege I don't even
understand what so what it wouldn't when
people compliment you on your tan that's
because of white privilege or could it
just be that they're being nice and you
should just take it at that rather than
you know implying that they're actually
racist no one will criticize me okay
well who does get criticized for a tan
are you suggesting that if a black
person goes to the beach and comes back
and their skin is darker that they that
people criticize them for it they go
will they walk into work and there and
people are openly criticizing the shade
of their skin I mean what what no one
will criticize you for your tan no one
criticizes anyone for a tan what does
that even mean of course that no one
would do that's what it that's white
privilege all right
another one says got financing to buy a
house as a 30 year old pizza cook I've
never been denied a line of credit
actually hashtag my white privilige okay
so if it's someone in your exact same
financial situation everything is
exactly the same except that if you had
darker skin you're suggesting that you
would not have gotten that line of
credit they would have said no we're not
gonna give it to you because your skin
isn't light enough another one says
sitting in a swanky hotel lobby using
their Wi-Fi all night as a non paying
guest hashtag my white privilige first
of all what are you doing sitting in a
in a hotel lobby all night using their
using their Wi-Fi I why are you even
what what would be this scenario or that
we even come up I mean get a room if
you're in the if you're gonna be in the
hotel all night using their using their
Wi-Fi another one says I gave birth in a
hospital twice and everyone believed my
pain and offered relief
hashtag my white privilige so giving
birth in a hospital so what part is
white privilege giving birth in a
hospital or you got pain medicine when
you were giving birth and that so if you
were a black woman they wouldn't have
given you pain medicine I'm gonna need a
citation on that I mean that certainly
would be rather shocking but another one
says called the police in Massachusetts
when I lost the key to my bike lock
white firefighters showed up didn't ask
for any ID proof that the bike was mine
or proof that I lived at that address
and cut the u-lock off without question
hashtag my white privilege why did you
call the police because you lost the key
to your bike lock that's you know that's
that's just I don't think that's a white
thing that's a rather absurd reason to
call the police that to me just strikes
me as a spoiled urbanite thing that's
what that is
upper spoiled upper-class urbanite which
we'll talk about this in a minute but
that's more of a social
economic thing it would never occur to
me if I lost lost the key to my bike
lock to get on to call 911 she did and
she did that and the police responded
helpfully and and and nicely apparently
and so her her reaction is to accuse
them of racism but really nice good
stuff there
now the hash tag has since become mostly
just jokes but thankfully but such as
the fate of all hash tags in the end a
hash tag either fades off early or it
lives long enough to see itself become a
joke but initially this is the kind of
thing you were getting so and it's all
it's all pretty ridiculous now I don't
deny that racism exists I don't deny
that there were certainly a time in our
country when white privilege was very
definitely a thing though not a thing
necessarily enjoyed by all white people
certainly not an equal measure but I
think today much of what we consider
white privilege and much of what we
chalk up as racial discrimination has a
lot more to do with age gender and
socioeconomic status I think that's some
of the confusion you're seeing with this
for instance as far as gender goes that
there were a whole lot of tweets from
white women saying talking about all the
times they've been pulled over and they
haven't gotten a ticket or whatever well
I can tell you that every single time
I'm pulled over for something I always
end up getting a ticket now I don't get
pulled over that often anymore I'll talk
about that a minute but if I get pulled
over I get a ticket I don't get out of
tickets
I've never gotten out of taken ever my
wife gets out of tickets all the time so
what we're both white so what's really
going on there no you see that's not
white privilege that's female privilege
especially if you're a young attractive
woman I don't think really matters what
your race is you're gonna have any
your time dealing with police than you
are if you're just a an ugly guy like me
now but as I said I think I think what
we've got here is AIDS gender and
socioeconomic status so for instance
there were these these white people
saying things like you know I have white
privilege because I've never been
stopped by the the cops for no reason I
because I can walk into a store without
people looking at me like I'm gonna
steal something I have white privilege
because I'm not prejudged at job
interviews regardless of my
qualifications and so on and as I as I
as I was reading those I thought to
myself well wait a minute all of that
has happened to me not much anymore but
it did when I was younger when I was
teenaged to early 20s I was pulled over
frequently before for dubious reasons I
had my car searched a couple of times I
had sobriety checks even though I I was
exhibiting no signs of inebriation
because I was not inebriated as I can
remember one things about I was maybe 21
or 22 and I got pulled over and and I
had like an hour before had one beer at
a restaurant and then I drove home and I
was perfectly fine it was not I wasn't
swerving or doing anything crazy but the
cop pulled me out had me do the whole
sobriety checkpoint thing I passed you
know got an A+ I was good to go so that
kind of even though there was there was
no indication I think he pulled me over
for going like 11 miles over the limit
and then next thing you know I'm doing
the sobriety checkpoint it didn't appear
to be any real reason for it but that's
what happened in as a teenager I would
definitely be watched suspiciously when
I went into stores in fact I remember
one time specifically I went into a into
a store thing might have been a Rite Aid
and I was walking manoj the back of the
store and i distinctly remember and I
could hear the guy at the register call
back over
over the radio intercom whatever not the
intercom but he called back to someone
who I assume was in the back of the
store another employee and he said watch
the guy with the hat he was telling the
other person to keep an eye on me
because he was afraid that I was going
to Shoplet there were well you know when
I was growing up there were some
restaurants around town and other
establishments where my friends and I
weren't even allowed to set foot inside
after a certain hour that wasn't a rule
that was singling us out specifically
but teens in general there were there
were places where if you were under the
age of 18 you couldn't go in with a
group unless you were with an adult
after a certain after a certain time and
but of course none of this was was
racial this was really about age and I
think to some extent gender as well so
when you hear how young black males are
treated I think oftentimes the young
male part is far more relevant than the
skin color part I think it's young males
young guys who are teenage early 20s
they're treated a certain way by society
and by businesses and by police officers
because certain assumptions are made
about them and not entirely without
basis because young guys tend to do
stupid destructive dangerous illegal
things and that's just the reality and I
think that's where a lot of this comes
from now these days I rarely get pulled
over unless I really am speeding because
usually I'm you know usually I'm I'm
driving my wife and my kids and I'm
dressed like a nerd and we're listening
to like The Wiggles soundtrack or
something in the car and I tend not to
attract a lot of attention from police
that way now why do you think why do you
think cops are not so suspicious of me
now but they were
when I was 16 17 18 like what why do I
hardly ever get pulled over now but I
got pulled over a lot at that age
especially if I was driving in a car
with four or five of my friends who were
also my age we tended to get
coincidentally pulled over a lot why do
you think that is I was white back then
- okay this isn't a Michael Jackson
situation now who do you think is more
likely to be pulled over a black a black
man my age who's also driving his kids
and his wife around in a minivan also
dressed like a nerd listening to kids
songs or whatever coming back from from
church or wherever else or a 17 year old
black teenager in a car with other
teenagers dressed like teens dress
acting like teens act listening to you
know having the music blasting and all
that who is more likely to attract
attention from police and in this
hypothetical the race is the same but I
think we all know that the
seventeen-year-old with the other 17
year olds he's going to attract more
attention because of his age and his
gender so age and gender refractors also
socioeconomic status status is a factor
if you're a white person living in a
trailer park where half of the residents
are on meth people are going to make
unflattering assumptions about you they
shouldn't but they will and I know the
response to that is people will say well
well a white person may be treated
unfairly but it won't be because he's
white well affirmative action seems to
blow a hole in that theory but even
aside from that where do you think the
term white trash comes from a poor white
person who lives in a trailer park is
going to be called white trash actual
Trent his existence is being compared to
trash to a heap of garbage so that
really seems to not only be
discriminatory but discriminatory in a
racially specific way we what else could
you call the term why
trash so there's socioeconomics element
to this as well but when we talk about
white privilege we talk about racism you
see all these tweets none of those
factors are even considered it's just
assumed that it has to always be racial
and that's what jumps out at you when
you read some of these tweets that or
any time this topic of white privilege
comes up it's just there is
automatically an assumption with no
evidence just an assumption that race is
the reasons so that woman says that well
I you know I as a white person I'm able
to sit in a hotel lobby and use the
Wi-Fi all night well again that to me
seems pretty weird and I think she
should be kicked out because you know if
you're not a paying customer but if
you're if you're assuming that you're
allowed to do that because you're white
then what you're really saying is that
the people working there whoever's
behind the counter who's not kicking you
out you're just assuming that that
person is racist you're assuming that
that person would kick someone out if
they were black and based on what first
to make such a unflattering accusatory
insulting assumption about someone you
better have some evidence for that but
you have no evidence you have no idea
whoever that person is behind the
counter you have no idea how they would
react if you were a different race
you're just assuming you're just making
that up
based on nothing and meanwhile that
person is being nice to you they're
letting you sit there and use the Wi-Fi
and you're sitting there stewing over
how racist they are for not kicking you
out it's the same thing with these
stories about other police that the
police were being nice to you they were
they were they were being helpful and
your response is to assume that they're
racist to say oh yeah well I bet you
wouldn't do this if I was black how do
you know that it's it's it these are
assumptions with no evidence that's the
problem if you're going to accuse
someone of racism you need to have some
kind of evidence for it but of course no
one feels any need for that anymore all
right
the movie unplanned came out this past
weekend it's the true story of Abby
Johnson the former Planned Parenthood
clinic director who left
Planned Parenthood became a pro-life
advocate and the movie shows how this
conversion happened I haven't haven't
seen the movie yet but I've heard good
things about it the film did remarkably
well at the box office I think it
finished in like fourth or fifth place
for the weekend which is impressive when
you consider the small budget for movies
like this and also the fact that various
TV stations refuse to run ads for it and
some funky things are happening with
social media with Twitter apparently it
would seem preventing people from from
following unplanned on Twitter and other
anomalies happening as well on social
media so the the the deck is stacked
against the movie as you might expect
with a pro-life movie and yet it's still
being as successful as that but the most
striking way that the powers that be
have tried to interfere with this movie
and prevent people from seeing it is in
the rating okay now this movie was given
an r-rating why was it given in our
rating well Abby Johnson wrote an
article explaining the two scenes that
earned it in our rating and it's really
these only only these two scenes it's
not like this movie has is filled with
profanity or sex or anything I I could
pretty much guarantee you there's none
of that on either on either score but
there were two scenes that earned at the
are rating and let me read Abby
Johnson's explanation or description of
those scenes and you tell me if you
think this earns it should earn it in
our rating so it says she says so why
they are rating for two scenes the two
scenes that the movie team was
determined to recreate accurately at my
insistence because they are important
for people to see the first is a CGI
recreation of what I saw on the
ultrasound screen when I assisted in the
abortion procedure that convinced me of
the humanity of the unborn you will see
what I saw a baby of an ultrasound on an
ultrasound screen and
I can white 2d you will see the abortion
instrument which looks like a big straw
in real life and like a dark line on the
ultrasound introduced into the screen
you will see the baby struggle against
it you will see the baby first slowly
then quickly disappear into the
instrument as it does what it is
designed to do it is important for you
to know that this was a CGI recreation
and not footage from a real abortion but
it sure looks like what I saw I think
this scene is so important for teenagers
and older children to see because it
feels it tells the the truth about what
our culture keeps trying to insist is a
right and a freedom no one will be able
to see this scene and then and then say
they don't know the truth about abortion
the second scene was that was cited as a
reason for the r-rating is a scene that
recreates my awful experience with the
abortion pill Ashley the actress who
plays me did a fantastic job capturing
both my physical pain and my fear I
won't lie to you the scene does show
some blood in real life i hemorrhage so
badly I thought I was going to die the
movie captures that without gratuitous
or without being gratuitous or gory I
think the producers walked that line
well ok so those are the two scenes and
they certainly sound like intense
harrowing difficult upsetting scenes but
they're not gory it sounds like there
she says there's some blood and in the
second scene with the abortion pill but
it sounds like there's not a whole lot
of blood but you see here's the problem
though the only way you could possibly
justify
a movie in our rating based on the two
scenes I described there is if you're
admitting that abortion is an act of
violence against a human being that's
the only way you could justify it in
other words the only a pro-lifer could
could possibly agree with the r rating
and IM pro-life and i don't agree with
it but if you're not pro-life youyou
couldn't possibly agree with that
because according to non pro-lifers and
and by the way i think the end pay at
the MPAA that you know the Motion
Picture Association III don't think that
they are stacked with pro-lifers I could
be wrong but I tend to doubt it so what
not what what pro-abortion people tell
us is that abortion is just it's it's a
just a medical procedure it's like going
to the orthodontist it's like getting
gallbladder surgery now let me ask you
if there was a movie that had no
profanity no sex no violence except it
did show a gallbladder surgery do you
think that movie would earn an r rating
it might earn pg-13 but even that I who
knows maybe it wouldn't even get that
much so how does that work if it's just
a normal medical procedure which is what
pro-abortion people say then how could
you possibly give that an R rating in
fact you should be as a pro-abortion
person you should be saying yes you
should be encouraging people to watch
the movie you should because because hey
it's just abnormal medical but there's
nothing absenting about it yeah go ahead
and see it for yourself it's no big deal
the that that's how you know that's how
you should know that something is up
with the pro-abortion side is because
they talk about abortion and these
dismissive terms saying it's no big deal
it's just a medical procedure or even
though they'll even paint it as a
positive and joyful and good thing so
they say all of that but it's so
conspicuous that in spite of saying that
they don't want you to see it
that's odd isn't it they don't want you
to
see it they don't they certainly don't
want to give graphic descriptions of it
to the women who are seeking abortions
they don't even want to show ultrasounds
they get very very upset at the graphic
photos of abortion that some pro lifers
will will you know will show but again
what are you upset about what are you
afraid of that's just it's just a
medical procedure and that's just a
clump of cells right it's not not a
person so who cares yeah I mean if
you're Pro borscht
you should be the one showing the
graphic photos because they're not even
really graphic according to you it is
again no big deal so there's there seems
to be a bit of a disconnect there
somebody wrote in to the show last week
and made another great point talking
about disconnects and contradictions
that you know
movies rated R then that means that
under the eight what is it 17 or 18 that
means under the age of I think it's
under the age of 18 right you're not
allowed to go watch the movie without
parental
you know consent yet in in most states
you can actually get an abortion under
the age of 18 without parental consent
so you can't watch a movie about it but
you can actually do it does that make
sense no clearly a dozen so if you had
any any doubts at all about about this
issue and and who exactly which side is
being forthright and honest then just
ask yourself why is it that the
depiction of an abortion which is done
as it seems like it's done as as as non
gratuitous ly as possible given what
it's portraying well while at the same
time being honest so why is it that that
would earn in our rating and why is it
the pro-abortion people don't want you
to be exposed to those kinds of images
when they say that it's just a medical
procedure I'm certain I've I have on
more than one occasion heard in abortion
or getting an abortion I've heard it
compared to going to the dentist well I
am quite certain that if a movie
depicted a person going to the dentist
they would that would not earn it or in
our rating that wouldn't even get it
above gee okay so there's something
going on here
alright let's go to emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com this is from Nathan says hi
Matt on the Sunday special yesterday you
said that all someone has to do is love
their spouse to get to heaven I was
shocked to hear this coming from you as
it is heretical the Bible says that the
only way to heaven
is through faith in Christ your
statement is false and dangerous yeah I
got several emails like this so I
thought I should address it I was on
Ben's Sunday special show yesterday
I thought it was a fun conversation good
conversation and in the course of the
conversation we talked about the
afterlife which actually was just an
extension of a conversation we were
having having off the air before the
cameras were rolling and then they said
just save that for the for the show and
so we did we kind of just picked it back
up when the cameras were rolling and he
asked me about my ideas of Heaven and
Hell and so we we talked about it from
that starting point at one point I posed
the question not a statement really but
a but a question can someone who has
love in their heart someone who loves
who truly loves not someone who just has
the emotional experience of affection
but someone who really loves can that
person go to hell
now notice I the question I'm asking is
can they go it's not even do they go but
but can they is it even possible or is
Hell a place entirely devoid of love now
I've always understood Hell as a place
that is devoid of love and I think you
know I I don't think anyone would would
would disagree with that that's how it
seems like everyone describes hell it is
a it is a place we don't we don't know
exactly we can't go into great detail
describing it but it does seem that it
would be a place completely devoid of
love there is no love or joy in Hell now
if love were a place where love I mean
if hell were a place where love can
exist then the whole idea of Hell is
just monstrous and I think untenable if
hell is a place where even the loving
and virtuous may be tortured for all
time then well I I just I find such a
thing
very difficult to believe but if we
agree that hell is a place where love
cannot and does not exist by definition
that is that's what hell is it is the
absence of love and joy if that's the
case then what about a person who never
comes to explicitly believe in Christ
for whatever reason but who really does
love their spouse or their child really
loves again not I'm not talking about
emotional affection which we often
excuse we often confuse with love I'm
talking about actual love can that
person go to hell is the question if so
then we're back at this problem where
well that means that love exists in hell
and that's not how any of us think of
Hell and by the way if a person with
love in their heart can go to hell then
that means that not just love is
existing in hell but then also a
things as well because think about it if
someone goes to hell and they love their
spouse let's say a man a man who loves
his wife goes to hell okay and then
let's say that his wife does not go to
hell
well the man is still gonna love his
wife and not only that but he's gonna
find some joy in the fact that his wife
is not with him that his wife is in
eternal paradise so that means that now
you've got love in hell
you've got joy in hell and you've got
selflessness in hell and it's all
happening inside a person who you know
it starts to seem is is pretty out of
place in that environment right a person
who has this selfless joyful love in
their heart what are they doing there
and and again how can they even be there
now I'm not the first person to ask this
question or to try to deal with it CS
Lewis as I mentioned on the backstage
special CS Lewis dealt with this and
that's the great divorce the book great
divorce which I mentioned on the show is
really deals with this a lot and his
solution to the problem was he basically
said that if you have love in your heart
any amount of love for anyone then God
can take the embers of that love and he
can fan them and ignite them so he can
he can work with him even if you come to
him just with those little embers he can
work with that he can take that he can
do something there the people in hell
are the people uh Turley devoid of any
love any virtue anything they've got
nothing going on it's it's complete
emptiness and God has nothing to work
with and so they're in hell but if even
if there's just that little little spark
that little spark of love then
is that something God can work with but
that that's part it just can't be in
hell I can't go there and that's what
great divorce is really all about and
that's you know there are all these
scenes and in the book the great divorce
where you've got these conversations
between P person who's coming from hell
and in the book you know you've got the
the people in Hell have this opportunity
and it's obviously all very allegorical
and poetic and everything he's not
suggesting that this is literally how
they afterlife works but in the book
you've got these souls in Hell who
essentially take a bus to the to the
outer rim of heaven and then someone
that they knew from their physical life
who is in heaven comes out to meet them
and essentially tries to convince them
to come to heaven but in almost every
case the person even though they're
heaven is being open up to him they they
decline it and they say I don't know I
don't they come up with reasons why they
don't want to go to heaven and the
reason why they declined the invitation
in every case is because they have no
love they don't they're hearing these
descriptions of what it's like to be in
a place full of love and selflessness
and it just doesn't appeal them they
don't want that so again not a clearly
not a literal description of how the
afterlife works but it's just dealing
with the concepts of well what is it
what does this mean and and we all say
that people who go to hell choose it
well how does that work why would anyone
choose it how does it work to actually
choose hell and that's what that's what
CS Lewis is trying to deal with I think
it makes a lot of sense so yes the Bible
says that we only go to heaven through
Jesus but that means that Jesus decides
who goes so who are we to say what
criteria he makes he uses to make that
determination and if you think that the
only criteria is just the intellectual
acknowledgement of Christ's lordship
that the only thing you need to do is go
oh yeah yeah Jesus is God sure
and and you get to go to heaven and
everyone who fails to make that
statement doesn't go then you believe in
a scenario where there are a lot of
really terrible awful people who happen
to believe in Jesus in heaven and a lot
of virtuous loving people who happen not
to inhale by the way along with every
single baby who's ever died because none
of them believe in Jesus
I find that vision of the afterlife to
be completely demented frankly and I
don't accept it and I don't think it's
biblical and let's also remember that if
God is love which I believe he is then
anyone who loves loves God even if they
don't know it all love is love for God
even if you don't know that's what
you're doing so if somebody loves God
without knowing it is God going to
eternally hold that against them or is
he gonna take that and work with it and
set it right that's the question
let's see here this is from Phil says
saw you on the Sunday especially
yesterday you were talking about
homosexuality and sexual abuse and the
priesthood what do you think of priests
marrying do pastors marrying solve the
problem in the churches that's an
interesting question
that's what I've been I've been thinking
about wrestling with if you'd asked me
three years ago about the idea of
priests marrying I would have said
absolutely not it's a crazy idea and
still today I I don't think it would
solve the problem as it were but it
would maybe address the problem partly
for this reason that there are a lot of
decent men with sexual appetites that
are in line with Christian teaching but
who would never want to be priests
simply because they also want the
companionship of a woman which is a
perfectly healthy and good desire to
have so the church is losing out on a
lot of good men who have all of the
qualities you want in a priest except
for the fact that they they don't want
to be alone and celibate for their whole
life they've got everything else going
they just don't want that
which which which is perfectly
understandable they want the love and
affection of a woman so maybe it's not a
good idea you know on second thought to
reject all of those men maybe it's not a
good idea to rule all those guys out and
there's also something to be said for
the fact that celibacy is a really
really really really difficult thing but
for a priest to break his celibacy
valve's is considered a grave sin it's
like adultery basically so we've set up
this dynamic where a priest has to
either have superhuman self-control to
be celibate his entire life or he's
gonna fall into grave sin and serious
scandal and so those are the two options
basically right now either you're gonna
have a superhuman priest or he's going
to fall into grave sin and scandal
whereas if you let priests marry then
you're expecting them to have just sort
of normal self chimera do you need
self-control too but not superhuman
don't need to be a superhuman to remain
faithful to your to your wife but you do
need to have some self-control
the problem with ruling out the guys who
have just normal self-control maybe not
superhuman self-control is that you end
up with a priesthood populated by some
superhuman men but then also a lot of
men who are not superhuman so then they
fall into deep sin and then it just in
and they fall deeper and deeper by the
minute and so you end up almost with
this dichotomy where a priest is either
going to be a saint or Satan there's
kind of like no room in between but
there should be maybe it's okay to have
priests who are normal just normal you
know they have normal desires they want
to be with a woman and and maybe they
should be allowed to fulfill those
desires in a way that is moral and
biblical in the context of a marriage so
you know I think that's the argument you
can make for as I said I just think
there are a lot of decent good men who
the Catholic Church is losing they're
losing out on because they're a whole
lot I'm telling you there's a whole lot
of guys who would certainly be priests
if not for that one little thing which
is not so little all right we'll see
we'll do one more this is from Brendan
says hey Matt big fan in fact I lately I
think I might enjoy your show more than
the ben shapiro show although I don't
tell him I said that well I just put it
out there I know you sometimes like to
answer questions outside of politics so
I have a football question for you do
you think teams punt too often in the
NFL does it make any sense to you that
teams ever put punt on fourth and 2 on
their own 40 it seems to me that teams
should be more statistically minded when
weighing their fourth down options
instead of instinctively sending out the
punt unit thought maybe you'd have an
opinion on this as your team has one of
the best punters in the league also as a
Browns fan I'm wondering what fans of
the other AFC North teams are thinking
or dreading about the Browns this year
PS can I get a shout-out to christen
dome college
yeah shout-out to Chris I actually have
two two of my siblings want to christen
them so in grade school yeah I think
I've talked about this before in the
show with punters III totally agree with
you in fact I think it would make a lot
of sense to just have a policy as a as a
as a head coach in the NFL that you're
never going to punt
once you get past your own say 35 yard
line once you're past your own 35 never
punt it just it
as you say it doesn't make sense
statistically when you punt the ball now
fourth-down is still a debt that's a
down where you have the ball and you can
do whatever you want with it you could
try to score you know every time you
have the ball it's an opportunity to
score well when you punt there's zero
basically zero chance of scoring unless
there's a fumble or something on the
return and you're just giving the ball
back you're saying all right you can
have it I think that only in the most
extreme circumstances in a football game
should you ever willingly give the ball
back to your opponent I think that's the
basic principle yeah I know that it
seems unorthodox because we're so used
to people punting but the game has
changed a lot and also over the over the
years and so I think this goes back a
punting may have made sense you know
2530 years ago but now especially with
these high-powered offenses and these
quarterbacks who can basically make any
throw on the field to willingly give the
ball back to your opponent I think
should happen a lot less often than it
does as for the Browns I think they put
together a good team but the thing about
the NFL's one of the reasons why I like
the NFL is that it's very hard to buy a
championship team I know they do it in
the NBA all the time but in the NFL it's
difficult to do and there have been many
teams that have gone out and free-agency
spent all you know a whole lot of money
getting all these high-powered fancy
free agents and then they win four games
in the in the in the season because just
because you get all the pieces together
on paper that doesn't mean it's gonna
come together on the field so maybe if
you're a Browns fan you could have a
little bit of optimism I wouldn't try to
take this from take that from you after
so many years of misery but also there's
reason for caution all right we'll leave
it there thanks for the football quest
you know I always enjoy those and I'll
talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
creepiness finally comes back to haunt
Uncle Joe Biden that's today on the Ben
Shapiro show